jesus christ what's going on you started
saying gross what happened i got dudes
messaging me talking about hey team
uncircumcised yeah that's gross
no no no it's a tribe no it's like a
group i don't i don't i don't want i
don't want soccer brothers why not you
have it yeah i have it but i don't need
to be like i don't need to bound with
people like just like hey man
no
but chappelle there are circumcised men
trying to grow their foreskin back they
want what you have they're trying to
grow it yeah yeah there are people who
stretch their uh like the skin on their
penis and try to regrow it yeah yeah i'm
just busy for [ __ ] like that
too busy for that though well take it
easy because you sent me multiple
pictures yeah you always send me your
dangling too busy no he sent me pictures
and you know what i love to think about
so i i i answered the first one right it
was funny
i went okay
and then i put lazy though because it
was a lazy picture because you see the
tip you see the tip of it he's in a robe
and it's just his dick and he sends
another one nothing's better when you
don't answer because that's like okay
like dude like i said oh you're like did
i well it was just cool
boundaries yeah it's just too heavy and
it was just it's late
was it the one we was dancing no this is
new this is yesterday oh bro calm down
hey but
when i get bored man you know i'm bored
when i do start doing that stuff yeah i
start talking to you about dumb [ __ ]
yeah and i don't entertain like i like
texting i'm like hey and another thing
about and you're like
no he'll be like hey do you think kobe
could beat jon jones and i'll just look
at it and then but it takes you a minute
though no i'll get you for will you get
because i'll see if something like you
have some actual talk about and then
when it turns into fight talking like oh
i'm out
or dicks hey chin what's the uh is there
more people on circumcised than
circumcision
100 more people there's more people
everybody in china is uncircumcised
everybody in the environment
unless you are catholic or christian
it's very common for you to be
uncircumcised most of india is probably
i think hold on the rate of circumcision
has dropped probably estimated roughly
80 of males thirty five nine are
uncircumcised eighty whoa
you guys are the minority look at that
oh they're the minority oh really yeah
hey i'm gonna have a boy what do i do i
don't do it why would you do it like
when you think about it it's just all
like for for looks that's all
just dude you're cutting a pizza let's
talk about it you're cutting a piece
of your baby's skin off for religious
reasons yeah that's not even no it's not
even he's not religious you're just
doing it if you're a religious side then
you have an argument you haven't really
just it's got to be painful it's got to
be so cute
and then the doctor goes no we give them
sugars in their head and that takes
their mind off i'm like
bro you could give me meth and if you
cut my dick i'm gonna feel it dude thank
you oh and what baby told you this you
[ __ ] scumbag yeah there's dudes that
do it as adults they'll get it done i
knew a guy who did it at 16. he
recruited it right after he would
be
yeah
yeah there are people that pierce their
[ __ ] i mean we know this stuff yeah but
on certain sizes
yeah like if you're self-conscious about
it i get it but i feel like in 2021 like
i don't care i told you i mean i got a
straight
fight fight about it i don't i don't
yeah so you wanted to leave it 100
percent i don't
what yeah what
cut my kids some kids lose their penises
because of it right infection very rare
even like that point one percent chance
yeah but still no small percentage but
either way i mean but i'm with you i
have to say though as a guy who's used
to seeing uncut [ __ ] see that's a
problem
but that's the problem
but in porno too like right you know
uncut dude the uncut dudes don't get no
jobs
they don't get no yeah you never see it
they get worked i would have had no work
oh yeah
that's just not uh
but it's not good you know what i'm
saying yeah or like like you met like
take take dicks out of it let's say
like big noses was like frowned upon a
religious thing okay son came out with a
big nose would you give him a nose job
off the bat i know it's [ __ ] insane
my son's ears
are literally like he could jump off a
building and glide to the ground right
he could get his way without he got
something he's got some big dude his
ears
i know a kid who got his ears pinned but
i'm not going to pin my son's ears pin
what do you mean you can no they can
so they fall back yeah oh no a lot of
people do that but my son's ears are
just he looks like you know does he say
i love yourself the way you do and i
will say this if i had a daughter and
she had a [ __ ] beak on her at like 16
i'm like all right girl that's what
we're going to do you would 100 if she
wanted it yeah that's why i started
raising dude
as a female if you got that [ __ ] life
changing like that penguin you got we
got to take care of it yeah it's like
you got to
you just got uncommon for girls at 16 to
get nose jobs not at all a lot of girls
do it
you're saying it's common yeah it's very
common for girls to get nose jobs and
[ __ ] are they turning eighteen
sixteen because listen listen i know
it's 2021 and everybody matters and
but at the end of the day that girl is
so self-conscious of her knows and
that good-looking people just get
farther in life it's science you know if
your big things don't make you ugly
that's not such a good example of a nose
job i know it's a tiny one i don't like
sometimes they can [ __ ] well well her
nose she looks like blossom that's a
toughness well that's oh that's it she
needed it no
well that's a grown woman her eyes are
something cool yeah she's got pretty
eyes how about that there you go like if
your son's on the left there yeah with
that [ __ ] ain't nothing wrong with
that i mean
it's not good i don't think there's
anything wrong with it but if you wanted
it well there you go that's it there you
go
that's that's that is that's an
interesting looks like jared leto in
that gucci on the left and then on the
right she looks like a normal human
being
she does bring that up chin bring that
up
but if you have a female in like they're
super self-conscious about it men men
and women always have done this i mean
those trials have been around for
guys getting those nose jobs oh for sure
dude you have to get a [ __ ] just
cannon on you dude it's not fun
although they say women are attracted to
men with big noses really yes that's
coming from a guy's big nose but that's
what i've heard yeah
and strong jaws and big eyes holy [ __ ]
yeah that's definitely what are we doing
it's tough
yeah god bless you now who's the actress
on the right there so ashley tisdale oh
damn she's from high school musicals
you know who had a nose job and it's so
distracting it's such a shame i think
michael jackson no he's dead you know
i'm talking current [ __ ] but um you know
who had a nose job where she got it done
you can clearly see she pays attention
to social media and it affects her
especially her mental space cardi b
cardio do you see her host of the emma
uh i haven't seen it but i've heard that
she had
such a shame like she was such a
character like she said worked on her
body i'm a super fan of it
but um
no no not there no no there's there's
gonna be one that she's still watching
her no like that's her nose on the left
which is damn yeah yeah yeah but no
that's not gonna go back
they did it from the amas though go back
to where you were
for this uh no just go back
so it looks like you're up there right
uh
wherever you were i mean look at her
nose right there that's terrible
going down go down where right where she
has that hair right there look at that
that's a problem this one yeah i don't
like that look oh the hair oh yeah
that's that's the who knows what this
but it's so distracting
like but that she's even had more done
than that yeah it's such a bummer match
she's so beautiful i know she yeah she
is beautiful there i like your nose me
too this is normal i love that now go to
go to ama type in that's how she looks
down right there no promise swear to god
yeah she like kept doubling down kept
doubling down keep doing it i'm sure
it's addictive doctor you'll find a
doctor at the tab and it's such a shame
because you're such a gorgeous bad teeth
right yeah she used to have bad teeth
and then she got veneers done and then
you know what she said about bad teeth
she goes they go uh why don't you do
your teeth before she was like oh
because i was worried i wouldn't be able
to suck dick the same
good good answer yeah good answer good
answer good answer good answer good
answer um you know who got plastic
surgery and does not look anything like
she did before
have you seen michelle uh k michelle
k michelle she's a singer before and
afters you would not recognize her now
really people yeah i mean number one's
kylie jenner i mean that's insane and
everyone's like her baby doesn't look
like that
oh wow oh my god see with that i'm a fan
of that's that's she
yeah that's [ __ ] impressive hell yeah
and you know how they get your jaw like
that shave it down fillers no they shave
it down fillers what do you mean a lot
of fillers yeah they do both
i thought it was i thought it's actually
they can do that with fillers so they
can they they they actually shoot stuff
in there they don't yeah so they create
the jawline right here with filler then
they put fillers in your chin so it
gives you that like kind of cardboard so
they like they don't have to like
yeah what i did too but but i found out
and they do that with their cheeks so
you'll see this and you'll see this and
you look like don't be surprised if i
come in
chiseled first of all look at how nice
you look like quagmire
how do you stay out of the sun like that
i was like
just who said this my aunt i was like
just do it yeah i just just woke up like
this yeah
look there's quagmire that's a jaw
that's me that's that's gonna be my
major job okay so john today's fight in
the kit is brought to you by athletic
greens the health and wellness company
that makes the best daily nutrition
really really simple man all right
there's a lot of stressors in life you
got everything going on you're trying to
get your diet right you got a busy
schedule maybe you didn't sleep great
your exercises whatever you got stress
from work you're not you're not you're
not eating enough man all right you
don't eat enough of the right things i
should say and that's that can cause
issues that's where ag-1 by athletic
greens comes into play we're talking
about a superfood product that brings
comprehensive and convenient daily
nutrient to everybody it's easy man it's
easy one tasty scoop of ag-1 contains 75
vitamins minerals whole food source
ingredients include a multi-vitamin
multi-mineral probiotics green superfood
blend all right it's all in one you put
it in a little eight ounces of water i
love the taste it's great you feel great
i promise you promise you you're gonna
notice a different all right
and if you wanna join the movement of
athletes podcasters comics dads moms
whatever it is
you gotta join the crew man athletic
greens is gonna give you immune
supporting free one year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com fighter today again
simply visit athletic greens.com fighter
take control of your health and give
ag-1 a try
there's a lot of apps out there i know
you guys will be searching the apps on
your iphones or your freaking
android you look at all the apps and
it's easy to find these investment apps
but just because it's easy doesn't mean
you know what you're doing that's what
makes wealthfront a lot different they
make it easy to invest and then we get
easy to get smarter about investing all
right after answering just a couple
questions wealthfront will build you a
diverse portfolio of low-cost induct
funds in minutes you can also build your
own portfolio with clean energy funds
crypto cannabis stuff that you love man
wealthfront even offers a responsible
portfolio a mix of funds built around
human rights climate change
sustainability diversity all right best
of all wealthfront is totally automated
they do all the trading all the
rebalancing they even help lower your
tax bill when you invest wealthfront is
trusted with over 27 billion assets
helping nearly half a million people
build their wealth right
this is great get your first 5 000
buckaroos managed for free for life by
going to wealthfront.com
fighter to start building your wealth
and get your first five thousand bucks
managed for free for life go to
wealthfront.com fighter that's
r o w-e-a-l-t-h-f-r-o-n t dot com
fighters start building your wealth
that's wealthfront.com fighter get
started today well like my girl's friend
who she's her best friend
she just had a [ __ ] you know she had
a she had a potato for her nose man it
was distracting and then she saved up
her money no she didn't make a ton of
money saved all her money yeah went to
the top doctor in beverly hills
and got the nose job done dude it is
worth it oh life-changing worth it she
broke up with her boyfriend the next day
yeah
good for her she's just some regular
dude now she looks like you dive she's
like [ __ ] i'm she's like oh no i'm at a
different level yeah
that's delicious
it's different i had a wealth
really different she's like oh see ya
dude yeah yeah your nose actually
changed a lot because
yeah i used to have like a like a kind
of pointy pointy nose look at brenda's
nose beforehand i'm trying to [ __ ]
enjoy what joey fatone from [ __ ]
insane you've had a lot of work done and
uh but in the opposite so that would be
look at that nose oh my god my nose
there that would be yeah that's when i
met you dude yeah whoa it used to be
super crooked look at that jawline bro
that's that's still there
oh that jumps down
yep you are skinnier you got a skinnier
face yeah you got a skinnier hair
100 yeah big time it's nothing a little
gua sha wouldn't fix what's that uh it's
a thing where you basically help drain
the lymphatic uh fluids from your face
so you basically like rub your face and
then it gets slimmer so it doesn't look
like like chunky you don't have to cuz
like everyone who eats when you get
inflamed you have a lot of like
lymphatic fluid built up so girls use
this like chinese technique where you
will like massage your face that fluid
goes away which then sharpens your
jawline naturally oh i don't know why
stevie has not always had a beard yeah
really fantastic especially
i love the beard hey cat where do i get
that oh you could get oh i'll show i'll
send you come back though uh you just do
it like every time you do it i do it
every single night as just like a
nightly routine oh but i gotta massage
my face every night
yeah you can't have a procedure never do
these things never doing that you yeah
but yeah you do this like once or twice
a night a bunch of girls do this
it works i think i'm beyond that don't
they have something that helps like
yourself chick-fil-a i had chick-fil-a
twice yesterday it's fine the gouache
shots you hold a little water in your
face the sodium
and you just get older and you know it's
whatever thank you but you think that
works cat it works for me
you're
is like the bloating the inflammation it
doesn't change that i heard you can get
a procedure done where they go inside
the mouth and cut out the fat that's
what uh the kardashians and the hadids
do where like a lot of them will have
kind of like baby like chubby face yeah
and then they take the fat out and
suddenly you have like a crazy uh bones
that's what i want to do but and do you
have to go under for that i don't mean i
think you do
i feel because it's your face 10 years
from now you're going to be able to grow
tissue and we're going to have a very
different conversation well i don't want
to grow tissue on my face i want to take
the like
we're going to be able to have chrissy
teigen but christie tegan also was in
the news because she got a eyebrow hair
transplant recently right anything she
post she gets lit the [ __ ] up yeah
because it's because she's talking
there's a hater trying to kill herself
terrorist person
piece of [ __ ] and then she's just so
like out of tune like she like she was
like and i'm canceled but what's up guys
here's my squid party and everyone's
like what the [ __ ] are you doing get the
[ __ ] out of here
she sucks yeah she's blowing that girl
for [ __ ] i've never ever i mean are
you kidding me and then she was trying
to be all nice about it gross yeah just
disgusting
i look into [ __ ] massage my face
though cat
try to do it for two weeks and see if it
helps every night though they say
flipping your head to the old trick in
ice water
i'll do it for you yeah why not be fine
we're beyond that
you do it right no i used to i tried it
it just your face
what i would do is when i had to do
makeup and i had my when i was doing
goldbergs or school
i would of course drink two bottles of
wine the night before eat all the sodium
i've always been able to eat whatever i
want problem is
your face looks like a [ __ ] balloon
like the other day remember when you
came in you go are you kidding me
because i had woken up at 11.
i would be all swollen and i tried i
would i was like all right i'm going to
start dunking my head and holding my
face in ice water
it doesn't really work no what happens
it's really fast
you're still swollen you're right these
are like frozen yeah yeah no but i think
we're beyond that dude i think we need
to go in for a two for one so your face
isn't that fat no i haven't
should
he has a good jawline now what we should
do is see if there's a doctor who would
take the fat on my face and give you a
hair thing oh well i want to get i'm
thinking about i mean why i'm going to
the knife one more time yeah i think so
right yeah it's getting worse you know
this i know because i stopped taking my
propecia i wish i got together you said
that for i get back up
but propecia it only it helps what you
have and nah but it's not gonna make it
thicker but if i if i go like you my
face and you're here
we're beyond like
one more like hymns or like we just one
more hair transplant then especially
with 21 science and [ __ ] technology yeah
they got all kinds of stuff yeah
yeah
neil gets it done like once every
[ __ ] month who doesn't theo he does
he just does it yeah he's scared to lose
his hair so he's gonna he gets from the
back and brings to the front you got
that strong hair yeah crazy yeah
yeah your hairline's like jay shop
losing his hair yeah he took his hat off
my dad's here stays like my dad's not
bald it's just back it's like it's
a full head of hair full set of hair but
he has like the widow's peak where it's
all the way back here like he salutes
like this your dad is good genetics yeah
yeah big strong guy yeah yeah
yeah we yeah i need to figure out how to
get fat sucked out of my face
i mean you could try that natural thing
cat just said i think you have what's
called the edema you hold water in your
face oh it's fat for example this is
what it did to bella hadid's face after
she had that surgery to get the fat out
of her cheeks
okay so what i hear is that's not what
they do again they they are putting what
is fillers in her cheeks yeah i'm
talking about the fat in her cheeks
or she's just starving herself
which i'm not gonna do
i'd rather have a fat face
again i'm beyond all that stuff guys i
love that you're honest with yourself
yeah here's the other thing they do they
pull your eyebrows up so they do this
yeah i brought threads yeah they pull
this up so your whole
your [ __ ] head is up like that and
now your eyebrows naturally do this so
the first thing to do with a lot of
girls if you see their eyebrows they're
down like that
that girl right there you see the one uh
yeah yeah wow i didn't know bella hadid
had that kind of that's that's a crazy
transformation your dad's a billionaire
dude
yeah you can buy looks i'll tell you
that you know all this surgery stuff you
know a lot of times he's had it done
chappelle oh because i got it
because i don't know
how many procedures including the skin
you're we're talking several procedures
excuse me hold on excuse me no excuse me
two hair plants sure two or three here
one hair transplant had two i swear on
my life i have one hair he had one he
had the lids done he had the skin
excuse me no i didn't have skin dressing
i had my oh yes
i had my lids done and by the way i
asked a bunch of questions i was
fascinated about how many people get
work done i was just fascinated with the
process i got to know the plastic
surgeon yeah but but
i've never had when you have a when
somebody goes
and they burn it off with with i with uh
dry ice
that's not a procedure that's just 100
of this
it's i if you have a sunspot you have to
burn off that that part so you don't get
skin cancer that's all you're doing yeah
sure so you get on your arms how long it
takes
to do it's that fast but then you did
your arms
kylie's like me too yeah me too three
minutes three minutes it's not even like
botox yeah in and out that's not a
procedure i've never had bones for an
hour guaranteed guarantee you're in
there overnight no no it's like this
look look watch
now go to your arms now go to your arms
now go to your arms yep keep going keep
going
keep going yeah that one's a little
longer that counts as a procedure
dude you've had four i'm having
i have i have skin cancer
you know i'm not i don't but you that's
a medical procedure no you did because
you don't like the spots on your face
it's a medical procedure it's like
people getting rid of freckles i'm with
you dude
it's
it's sun spots that's not a procedure
you can't call it that counts okay
doesn't count i had my lids done i had
three i had two plastic surgery things
like my lids and my hair transplant lids
is the biggest thing you've done but the
hair transplant didn't take i don't know
if you know that well that you did in
the night well i had bad hair for it so
what what what the guy said is he goes
your your scalp's very tight and you
don't have good hair for this and you
still went through it so it didn't
really it didn't really take so yeah do
you have that scar like rogan yeah you
do no you don't let me see
yeah
you can't see it but it's it goes like
oh yeah if you shave your head
completely you'd see it out of the way
rogan's is lower
he's had like three but now now i have
they take they take uh one follicle at a
time yeah there's no scar now yeah no
there's nothing kelly's had uh a few
done his is really good he's here he got
that kelly
but there's nothing to do about that
yeah
you can put it there
but i think it's it takes better when
you do it younger that's why theo does
it yeah he's not that young he's a nice
looking guy
yeah machine on camera
why not machine guns from colorado yeah
no yeah he's from ohio he's not though
born and raised in colorado two's 14 and
moved to ohio when he's 14. so he's a
white boy
yeah but he's from colorado we claim him
yeah jer pivens is fantastic too
wow and jamie foxx
yeah i don't see why you think it's the
best of all yeah
i'm kidding i'm having played george
costanza on seinfeld
our boy logan paul looks like he's uh
he's he's is he here yeah he's he's
losing his hair a little bit no yes he
is i noticed that actually a while back
oh the forehead area for sure he does do
that thing where yeah he does like that
he's recovering i can see that it's okay
he'll get it done too he's so rich too
yeah we have that money i don't i don't
know why you wouldn't do it i don't ever
i don't know why everybody would crazy
crazy expensive isn't it no it's like
ten years dude i'm still holding out on
on track
ten grand for like to change your life
like that yeah to have good hair [ __ ] if
you're not on trt and getting your hair
done i don't know what you're doing
stevie stevie do you not want to
optimize
do you not want to be the
and i love that functional fitness [ __ ]
and i'm doing awesome and stevie stevie
uh is looking at me and he goes he goes
there no mirrors here i go well maybe
over there he goes all right so he's
kind of like trying to look around and
i'm like you want to do an internal
class he goes nope
and so i i go guys let's start with some
jump rope well brian didn't really
stretch out i had a show that night i
pulled my calves
so badly that remember the guy yeah and
he rolled it out and he saved me he
saved me i was like i don't think i'm i
can't walk i got a man and he's like
[ __ ] pulled you would be back it was
it was a crazy crazy crammer ice cream i
felt like it was a but it was it wasn't
quite cramped yeah oh it wasn't he
rolled it out and you were better yeah
yeah that's a cramp
don't say
but then he rolled it out the worst
that's all right i thought it was done
don't worry you know who else is losing
their hair is uh bradley martin yeah oh
yeah oh damn dude yeah i wouldn't see
why he wouldn't get it done like just
get he's got him you know yeah he looks
like joe pesci from home
oh yeah yeah he took his half like damn
joe peggy yeah i feel like it's okay
though because he can he can hold he can
i feel like he's not a terrible person
with one hand i don't know why jay
doesn't do it too but he doesn't look
bad like buzzed right that's i think he
looks great there yeah he wears hats
it's usually a telltale sign when you
wear hats all the time i work
i do too though but i'm growing my hair
i wear hats all the time but i just it's
a beast to do my hair i like him back
then when he was thinner
when he's
yeah you don't like how he's all big now
yeah should get it done
yeah i don't know why jay doesn't do
something i've talked to him like do
something
hey you know what's going dude yeah yeah
he spends his money on fashion dog i
don't know he's into that he likes
[Applause]
[Applause]
i'm what i find impressive about him is
he's so [ __ ] athletic and strong his
ability to dunk a basketball he's just
got crazy power crazy power you see him
dunking basketball how easy it is for
he's a freak he's just like whoop boom
you sweetie you see when he jumped up to
his truck he sweeped him though
he did sleep yeah
no comment there's a there's a like i
feel like we do like a three for one
type of thing like you jay bradley like
all you guys go together all right and
then between your guys social media like
what company won't be all over that i'd
do it yeah [ __ ] yeah i'll do it in a
heartbeat you can even do three wigs
hey
again bro you always know you always
know that i get angry when you say that
why don't say it and don't say it like
it's a [ __ ] a good idea yeah don't go
three weeks
dude i would rip your wig off
[ __ ] just [ __ ] poop like a world star
street fight with two black girls their
wigs are always the first time you get
weaved up
there you go that's going to hurt yeah
you could do that but this is [ __ ] my
hair is getting [ __ ] it's terrible and
even here i gotta can i wonder if i can
get here oh yeah
you're just waiting for the wheels to
fall off like you are it's gonna be too
late and then you're gonna go to get a
trt you're gonna be 60 and they're going
to go cool you should have been here 20
years ago yeah
yeah but stevie's right like you know
waiting once you're on you have to stay
on though right who can you shoot once a
week
you don't get five minutes and you also
don't have to stay on there's other
like you guys feel good huh i feel great
brian are you really going to do it
though but i feel as though as they're
giving you the motivation
i work out enough so that i get sore if
it's going to help me not be a sore and
recover better yes
because you can feel great but like it's
it's it's still
it doesn't matter how you feel that's
only a symptom you like the way you are
stay there okay
dude you're on trt and some a [ __ ]
wig this guy's delicious
no i'm sorry not a wig if we got trt
hair transplant what do we want i'm
gonna look good man yeah you'd look
really good you're really [ __ ] all
right
[ __ ] it just killing it give me the kid
again you know i'm just fine
i don't want to [ __ ] out my endocrine
system i feel like that's no it doesn't
it's funny and you'll still have it oh
that's fine yeah you probably have more
yeah yeah you're not gonna have less
yeah it takes me rock hard all the time
it is now right now yeah you say your
testosterone's like i woke up this
morning with a dick that could cut a
diamond nothing about that would blunt
its claws yeah now think about even more
even more like do you not want more do
you not want to even knife yeah
i don't know why chin doesn't get on it
too
yeah i'm going to get on it that's why i
didn't know you were honest i would
actually ask for someone else work out
though
i know but like i think i got to work on
you just do testosterone without working
out no of course not going to help it's
a little motivation to work out because
i went when i got tested the doctor i
was like an anomaly because my test was
so low and the guy was really normally a
lower [ __ ] yeah low is 300 i was 106.
what holy [ __ ] why and the guy that's
what he said he was just like what is
going on here he's like what do you do
for whatever like six yeah i was like
106 how'd you not blow your brains out
well he was like are you tired i was
like all the time because i sleep for 12
hours a day and i'm still like
and then he just equated through he was
like so what have you been doing for
work i was like i used to be a porn star
he was like this makes no sense
i was like because how are you able to
get it out yeah because my sex drive has
always been super high and he was like
that's one of the many symptoms he's
like you can have a great sex drive but
your tests can still be super low wow it
just comes out in different ways yeah
heartache with your sad panda yeah mine
was 106. it was like
um it was 106. but you also had done
steroids before doesn't that that can't
that [ __ ] with you but i mean it was
damn near 15 years ago yeah you know so
long ago he said it was it was a
combination of just that the chemo the
chemo
you said i should have been on it right
when i got out of chemo 100 yeah
it should be a protocol they do so it's
not a bad thing to take no no he was
like
that's the problem with it it's like
like if you were deficient in iron or
magnesium went to the doctor they'd give
you a supplement to get you to a certain
level where your levels are good yeah
testosterone's
i'll never take it
well we'll see
like if you're deficient in something i
don't know why yeah why you wouldn't
like it because people are like oh it's
steroids like no no no no no
if you're deficient why why do you have
to inject it
well you don't have to you take a lotion
it's better to inject this
injecting it's just better when you take
when you take uh it once a week it's a
it's a slow release right yeah yeah yeah
so i just do once a week because there's
testosterone i know some people do lower
quantities every day though yeah some
people like to i was just in the mindset
that like if i'm traveling like doing
the road or something i don't want to be
doing having to bring a [ __ ] kit with
me yeah yeah you know i'd rather just
but it doesn't mess with the heart or
anything like that i mean if you do a
ton of that's why it gets lumped into
like these bodybuilders that do a
hundred dollars if you're running like
ronnie coleman yeah like in all
different types of things they say show
me the bodies like steroids don't
actually kill people like it's very rare
i mean you can have i would imagine
there's actually there's actually no
evidence right i do think that when you
take a lot of roads like the rock you
you it you look older like you're you're
your face
gets signed me up he looks younger than
both oh i disagree i disagree
you're here
look at that line see that line
you see the cheeks though they get those
they get those weird kind of shitty
cheeks
[Applause]
shitty cheeks hey listen again i love
you man
you look like [ __ ] next time that's a
lie and so do i look he's we both got
everybody in here besides captain good
body [ __ ] he's got a good vibe i'm just
saying his face has no deep lines we
don't even start your body compared to
his i'm saying his face
bubba what do you think your face is
better look at my look the biggest
action store in the world look
no i see it but i don't have those lines
you have crow's feet
you know you have crow's feet [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you have more lines on your forehead
than he does here let me take a photo
okay here let me take a photo of you
okay pull it up yeah yeah all right
be cool yeah
[Laughter]
this lighting's [ __ ] [ __ ] he's in
the middle of the sun all right just
bring it up man i'm [ __ ] pissed off
right now
you look great though brian don't let
anyone make it
younger than the rock though
are you [ __ ] me
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me well i got
gray hair you look good actually brian
looks pretty damn good here
yeah that's actually really good he
looks great he just doesn't look as
young as the wrong yeah it's just a
weird thing to go for the rock yes
it's like me saying what else it's like
me saying i look better than jared leto
yeah you know what i'm saying it's like
no you don't yeah
that's the comparison let's try another
person yeah how about my nose how about
my nose yeah you gotta know that that's
a nose
no one's inviting you to me to cocaine
and by the way that whatever surgery i
had on my lids it's no longer no
it's made it work
two weeks after my dude your lids look
worse it's no longer so
hey you tried i tried yeah
you know what's weird your lids are so
heavy it's like your eyes are just all
black like you can't see any white you
can't see [ __ ] no my eyebrows suck you
look like one of the guys from midnight
masks
you got a great smile though yeah i
don't know about you
i gotta i gotta shave my beard dude hold
on hold on hold up
look at the whiteness of the rocks teeth
compared to your
corn nut tea
how no hold up how
dare you
important dude you have
you have don't call me dude you have
fritos for teeth and you're gonna call
out dwayne the rock johnson he's got
some good he's got some very white teeth
that's baking soda or something yeah
whatever yeah oh looks like i gotta get
some work done i gotta go to the doctor
and i gotta see what we can do
whatever he's running uh sign me the
[ __ ]
i gotta run some gear here i gotta run
how old is rock now fifty
fifty dude it's amazing how you know he
wants to be the next james bond you hear
that
he could do it not a bad call
he's just so big like bond's a spy 49
like
so you're gonna have a spy of six for
260 pounds all muscle like you're not
blending in even though you're a tuxedo
yeah a little bit oh and then you're
gonna fit in an aston martin daddy
that's what he drives yeah that's uh
yeah he can't be a [ __ ] can't be a
spy in england in your f-150 yeah you
know what i'm saying oh [ __ ] no they'll
figure it out though but i feel like
you're you're as big as he is or are you
bigger you think
he's bodybuilder-wise bigger he's he's
he weighs more than me yeah probably
more muscle yeah better we all like same
height
yeah he's five but he's definitely not
six five okay i've been an elevator with
him and i and i was like oh we're eye to
eye and i looked down he had platform
shoes on like this big
but naturally i'm bigger than him
that's what you know it's a height yeah
better genetics
way better do you have a better job no
he has more better genetics no i'm not
dude i'm a real
he's a better athlete
who's a better athlete i went farther in
my athletic career than him so if you
want to didn't he play all four years
miami at my behind warren sapp it
doesn't matter yeah didn't sniff the nfl
didn't
oh i was a professional athlete for
seven years brian top ten in the in
the world okay but hold on i'm just now
he does action movies i know the [ __ ] i
tell dick jokes but as far as pound for
pound football he played they played on
a higher level all right i mean
university were all the same position no
we i we played miami oh you did yeah we
played miami okay you know both division
one yeah
and i played as much as he did
yeah okay yeah okay oh he had warren
seven from joe kloffenstein and lawrence
vickers yeah he's not hall of famers he
said that warren zappos he realized that
he was just not made for the nfl when he
played against against warren well with
warren said
it's like who's my buddy who who tried
to cover he had to cover
uh uh randy moss is your buddy white no
and he uh my buddy leo tells us he has a
whole bit about it he goes oh leo
flowers he goes i had to cover randy
moss and i was leo cornerback i was like
uh was he the tallest court in the world
camera were they playing pick-up
six too that's huge for a quarterback
but he was like free safety i think but
he said he said he had to play he had to
cover he goes in a real game it was so
different in a real game he played a
ball state or something i don't know
well that makes sense he played at
marshall so yeah i think they're saying
conversation yeah but he said he said it
was it was so astonishing but he knew
before that before yeah i mean you know
he didn't even try out for the nfl he
was like no
not not not for me
well you'll know because you won't get
an offer it's not like he was like i
could have but it's just not for me no
the nfl goes but don't they say some
guys walk on what is that about even
then like me as a free agent i have to
get still recruited in prospect from the
nfl like you you you know going to your
junior year and i watch that hard knocks
i mean you have that means nothing but
i'm just saying no but i'm saying like
the chances of making the team
are so
these are good players i mean they're
[ __ ] they they play what i didn't
realize because i didn't realize that
you can play
in the pre-season that doesn't matter
yeah and this isn't no and they gotta
cut the roster down yeah 53.
i don't know i think that's so cool
i didn't know leo played
four years no his neck is
he [ __ ] his neck up so bad that he was
paralyzed for a little while really yeah
really bad
really bad brendan
was paralyzed he actually was damn like
bed like bed rest paralyzed for years no
not years he he had a major neck injury
for real and he's paralyzed the whole
body i think
brian i'm not listening to you anymore
probably i had a neck issue but
paralyzed i think so
like bed rest can't move
yeah for how long
hold on let's find out hey do we think
this is an old college football story
no i think he was really [ __ ] up no no
hey [ __ ] up i get it
paralyzed i think he couldn't move
for how long i think for like like uh
you've reached leo flowers please hey
leo did you ever get
i think he was i think he had stingers
and stuff though you know huh he had
stingers no no i think he literally had
to go he was uh paralyzed for like uh
two weeks or something
for real like
that's crazy man i never heard that yeah
and then just came back yeah yeah you
can have that happen oh do you have
surgery yeah he had major surgeries yeah
yeah that major surgery but dude
paralyzed and in fact it's that's crazy
right he's still [ __ ] up over it i
mean still bad you know paralyzes
intense
and that never happened
when you get a neck injury sometimes you
can go paralyzed for a short period and
i've had really bad neck issues yep
really bad no but my my exes my my ex my
current girlfriend's mother was
paralyzed does she play football
she had a major injury but she was
paralyzed for
almost nine months nine month damn
bedridden nine months yeah and then for
real and then what happened and then how
did she come back sometimes in a spinal
cord injury through rehab you can bruise
the spinal cord when you sever the
spinal cord you're [ __ ] super fast if
you if you bruise the spinal cord
and it's [ __ ] crazy so you can have
the exact same injury as someone else
and that person is paralyzed forever you
bruise the spinal cord and they they
can't work
some people [ __ ] for whatever reason
like you have the exact same injury on a
cat scan you bounce back and they don't
know just like instant so she was doing
rehab and she wasn't able to uh they
said you're not gonna write your name or
anything right it's really bad
and she started to get her feeling back
in her feet and her hands because she
had a
a pole hit her in the back of the net
dan what was she doing she was in a tent
and a [ __ ] uh wind hit and the tent
got the the pole flew and she was facing
deep it was crazy it was a horrible
thing she got [ __ ] up she got [ __ ]
up concussion i'm sure no no broken neck
not like as interesting
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a broken
neck you know i'm talking about like a
year yeah like some ridiculous year and
a half yeah
yeah like almost dead
and they said it but so she's doing a
rehab with the rehab
thing they told her she'd never walk
again yeah yep yep and then this guy
didn't get feeling it wasn't getting
feeling back and he's like why is this
happening wait who what guy
so you're when you're in a group the
doctor when you have catastrophic injury
and you're at the hospital you're
working with other people who can't move
one dude had the exact same injury and
just never regained anything
but your girl's mom did yeah
that's it just it just randomly happens
yeah hey but you hate distinguishing the
rest of your life hey god is good
i'm not doing that right no god is good
no and i don't like your attitude i'm
annoyed i'm not buying any of this but
god is good i don't like god no dude god
is good leo was paralyzed and so is your
that's a fact soon to be mother-in-law
that's a fact both paralyzed and both
made it back
yes
lieutenant dan come on god is good get
your fist dude god is good give it up
get your fist dude god is good get your
fist adam i
get your you know what your promise you
hang out with whatever friends you have
now and you tell these stories
and they're like oh that's crazy man
everyone shares paralyzed stories and
not one person goes
hold on he's paralyzed for how long like
no one asks questions you know what i'm
saying listen listen if you weren't
actually if you weren't here you would
buy it oh i'd buy at all yeah but that's
a fact about smile coordination no
people come back all the time you do go
you go you can use
no no no there is no there is that dude
do you know there's some people that get
knocked out and then they wake up
speaking like mandarin or some [ __ ]
that happened to your girl's mom too
that can happen
that's crazy or they they just know
french
well it's funny you say that because
they're happy she speaks french people
that have had bad news no i'm saying
they i'm sweating
with him
there's a lady who like is in a coma for
like seven like latin or something she
woke up and started speaking straight up
mandarin like perfect mandarin
god damn yeah there's some weird things
yeah explain it that that's like that's
like so william patty who wrote the
exorcist yes remember the exorcist
that was based on a kid in egypt
who was speaking who had a i mean he was
a journalist yep and all these people
came and
there he started speaking in aramaic and
old aramaic that so the bible was
written in aramaic and greek he was
speaking in that ancient [ __ ] that
christ spoke yep and now eric was
written off a girl in uh
yeah in america no no this was in egypt
actually but that's a different story
there's an actual case
that that's a true story yes so they say
i don't know if i buy it or not you
believe that [ __ ]
i don't know i really i don't it's like
the bottom line is [ __ ] when you wake up
like i mean you can be exposed to
something and you might speak i might
think it's just some words
[Music]
and you might be speaking gibberish and
it's like he just said that's a sentence
but that old school latin like no one's
learning that's true also yeah how many
people are working
though back in the day you did learn
latin you learned latin and aramaic
aramaic is a weird thing like there were
all these stories who the [ __ ] knows i
personally don't believe any of it
because i don't think that happens well
did you they made a movie with that
little boy who was in a uh coma i forget
what happened to him and then when he
woke up his like whole description of
meeting god and being in heaven like it
is like and he's like sick
like my son like obviously he lies and
[ __ ] but it's like
we're talking about details like the
details that kid had you're like where
the [ __ ] does six-year-old get it's a
true story oh yeah they made a whole
movie i mean there's like a successful
book off of it remember that kid was all
over the
my son when he was five or four and i
told remember i used to joke but it was
all based on a true story where my my my
ex walked in
to my son finn and finn goes
oh there's my other mommy yeah and she
goes your other mommy was the mommy you
were talking to and he goes in the
closet yeah it's scary how about when he
wanted me to get rid of all the stuffed
animals because they're like talking
because they eat no because they bite
him at night and i go they bite you at
night and he goes yeah i go um i go
where do they bite you i don't see any
marks he goes they bite me on the inside
of my body and i went
oh this is a [ __ ] creepy so did you
burn those
i got rid of those those [ __ ] uh
stuffed animals here you got it
[ __ ] on fire you know what he
is an imagination like his dad
but still
they're really biting him on the inside
[Laughter]
bro what man i'm going with you on this
listen
there are some times where i will fight
you yeah this is one of them i feel like
you're going to i thought i feel like i
feel like you're going to do right now
dude i thought you were going to fight
me off the rock stuff i got to be honest
and then when you talk about leo being
paralyzed i was like this is definitely
going to do it and then here we are here
we are
yeah it is weird though those stories
they're a little weird huh
that's scary
dude what about the young black kid who
was adopted by a white family and then
dude first round draft pick
you know what i'm saying that goes
through the white family dudes
it's not athletics god is good god is
[ __ ] yeah there it is god's good i
love when people say that i said to my
girl last night
out of nowhere
she was saying someone like god is good
like your dad like found a job or
something like god is good i love she
was like what i love i do [ __ ] like that
to my girl cause she doesn't it's silly
she was talking about how this masseuse
was talking about she's talking about
this and that about babies and stuff and
i and i was as i'm listening to her i'm
slowly slowly pushing my chest out and
sucking my stomach in now i'm standing
like this i'm looking at it and i go
she say anything about me
and she goes no what i go
she's saying
she goes
why would she say anything about you i
go i don't know
just random [ __ ] [ __ ] off no the best is
god is good god is good man or praise
god i like to say praise god
god is good god is good he's good
the next time i send you a picture of my
dick that's just gonna take that's good
yeah
that's good those are lazy pictures last
night stevie's got everybody beating
this room with with dick's eyes
apparently kyle has a dick on him what
the short king has a dick on we found
out last night
i think i don't think i'm beating stevie
but yeah steven but i be i think if you
go pound for pound if we go pound you
you're like mighty mouse you got a
diggle he's jon jones you're mighty
mouse i do
what do you think i pull on tour yeah
you got it that's it yeah i just pulled
it that's that's how i pulled it yeah
one thing god gave me didn't give me
height he gave me length have you
you've always had a big dick um yeah i
didn't realize it until until i got out
of like high school that really in high
school your kids weren't like oh you got
a big dick no yeah i didn't really hook
up that much in high school so it was
after oh you were fat though
yeah
yeah you were fat in high school you
ever seen the you're you're seeing kyle
as fat that kyle was not good bro don't
look at him
was almost 300 dude pound for pound
though i think kyle might have you beat
he was so fat let's take a look
let's take a look at that american
friend i don't tell you you're fat you
live on junk food man his fat is like
205. kyle how old were you when you got
that fat um i was 20
21 22. and what was the diet at the time
uh i was eating a big mac and two large
fries every night for dinner every night
every night just about yeah and i would
i hadn't gone to the gym in like three
years you just love big macs i had never
had one that's you know look at you oh i
think kyle got your beat but yeah let's
see pound
was short and super what were you doing
were you eating just a lot of junk food
not correct i didn't know how it wasn't
from korean food it was from korean food
yeah right
we all say very american as well ramen
fast food eel sauce
you know sugars and neal sauce
how big my head was
the size of a pumpkin yeah yeah i guess
yeah i was like
that guy gay or is he is he
is he holding you on his shoulder he's a
big bodybuilder he's a good looking he's
holding you on his shoulders yeah is he
a cheerleader
he he might have been so he was good
yeah he's a bodybuilder
yeah
it was
there but again i'm five five five and
he'll say well you're five five what 178
180 that's gross
she's got some traps on her yeah she's
she's still really really tough good for
her oh
she has some same size chest as callan
yeah that's a big that's so funny that
dude is just holding you all up like
that now when a girl has traps like that
is that trt is that some kind of a thing
i don't think so isn't that where you
can usually tell somebody's doing too
much no not with females because some of
those females some of them are just you
know even guys too like genetically like
some are beasts he's definitely i know
girls who are jackman they're just yeah
huge dicks yeah chin you might have won
bud what's up yeah
for some reason i thought you're a
fatter kyle
you know maybe it's just five five one
eighties i felt fat that is fast like
jonah hill and moneyball for a while
well you're five five yeah i think so
yeah
we'll say five four though
yeah yeah he's five four one eighty
though right around there
five four one five five minutes in your
six three
six three six two yeah and i'm also 180
you're six three but you were you were
three hundred yeah chin my husband beat
285 do you wanna say 300 but it was a
285
i would you i would weigh myself every
day like holding yours down 285
potential let's take another break from
chatting with the bros cause listen it's
thanksgiving we got a lot to be thankful
for family food and free brats free bats
that's right with draftking sportsbook
the official sportsman partner the nfl
all right and they got a turkey day no
brainer you don't want to miss new
customers can bet just one dollar on any
turkey day nfl game and win 100 in free
bets if either team scores a point you
have the bears and lions so we'll see
what happens there but either way it's
gonna make the game better if you get
money on it right if sportsbook is
unavailable in your state yet you can
still get in on the thanksgiving nfl
action make your first deposit and you
can play free for millions with
draftkings daily fantasy contests
draftkings is safe secure reliable best
of all you can deposit withdraw whenever
you want download draftking's sportsbook
app right now use promo code fighter bet
just one dollar on any thanksgiving nfl
game win 100 and free bets if either
team scores a point that's promo code
fighter this thanksgiving at draftking
sportsbook the official sports band
partner the nfl must be 21 or older new
jersey indiana pennsylvania only new
customers only restrict supplies see
draftkings.com for details gambling
problem call 1-800 gambler this next
sponsor one of my favorites man i don't
do anything stand up
podcasting the milling podcast i do i
don't do anything without taking some
kratom that's right if you've always
wanted to try kratom now is the time
because with super specio they got you
covered man kratom is an all natural
herb related coffee plant that's been
used in thailand for centuries forever
kingdom helps energize your mind relax
your body just helps you feel good
that's why i love it and superspeciosa
has the only one ingredient we're
talking about pure kratom leaf that's
why i trust them man because we're going
to try kratom you got to make sure it's
pure kratom all right for beginners
recommend capsules because they're easy
to use me and chin use the powder
because we're psychos all right we got
you man i recommend if you're trying out
for the first time the green md strain
it's the most popular it's the best
selling if you don't like the way you
feel you can get your money back
guaranteed all right we got you covered
man for the month of november only it's
black friday all freaking month it's all
black friday all month with super specio
get an extra 20 off on top of the usual
20 for the code fighter try kratom get a
massive 40 off your entire order go to
get super leaf dot com slash fighter use
the promo code fighter for 40 off your
entire order for the month of november
all right
so again that's 40 off man 40 off and
you've always want to try kratom get 40
off all november they're doing black
friday all november with 40 off go to
get super leaf dot com slash fighter use
the promo code fighter for 40 off your
entire order for the month of november
this episode of finally kid is brought
to you by the one the only the mainstay
of this show we're talking about on it
supplements
listen if you're gonna get your man or
your women a gift and you need something
that's healthy and it's gonna get their
thick ass in shape you gotta give them
the best supplements the best fitness
gear on the planet that you can trust
that you know it's made with quality you
know it's backed by science we're
talking about on it.com on it.com
everything you need to get ready for
2022
whether they start january 1st whether
it's a christmas gift whether it's just
a gift to say you know what get your
thick ass in shape on a dot dot com
slash fighter has 10 off the entire
freaking website alpha brain if you want
to try it new mood shroom tech protein
powders coffee fitness gear protein bars
protein everything man mct oil we got
you covered man fat butters okay we
gotcha all right fitness gear we got
freaking kettlebell steel club maces we
got streaming fitness so you don't have
to go to a gym anymore on it in 30. on
it in six barbell body weight durability
kettlebell steel club steel mesas we got
it all man don't wait for january 1st to
get your thick ass in shape let onit
help you on your journey to get skinny
on it.com slash flight or 10 percent off
potentially heaviest you've ever been
uh when i was playing for the utah blaze
i was 273.
and they wanted to get to 300. what do
you know and i was like check please i
literally i got my car and drove home
back to denver that day oh yeah
you got the [ __ ] out of there that was
maybe your lowest point that's up there
it's up there you grew your hair long
and just sat in your basement for a
little bit right yeah yeah yeah
yeah and my testosterone's always been
low has it yeah i always hover around
like 280 300.
why is that for a guy like that's not
that much head injury no i got diagnosed
in college
yeah they gave me uh they diagnosed me
with low testosterone in college but you
can't get trt exemptions at division one
double a yeah i think so like you're
something you have to deal with but they
say that you're still repeated head
injuries
can be uh
maybe i mean my dad signed up for uh pop
on or uh tackle football seven yeah
yeah
and you're resting at 250 right now
yeah i'm 2 50. i was 252 yesterday
it's good yeah let's be 230 your body
holds that pretty naturally man
i mean two thirty fives
it's the is there anything when you were
gonna try to do 205 what a nightmare
that would have been i got down to 221
and i was fasting and eating [ __ ]
vegan i mean you don't have a gut no i'm
just a thick dude yeah yeah i'm like
marwana it's like no good
you know i had to
i just sit in because they're editing
the special is there anything worse than
watching yourself on tape the worst it's
the worst like so what do i do i'm like
like you don't put on like burn at all i
agree do you have any is there any
camera that makes me look slimmer
and why didn't somebody tell me how big
i am
[Laughter]
we were all black too
yeah for the stage and everything that
was the best yeah
um but i was like why don't you tell me
i'm being him you're a big kid yeah
because you've been lifting heavy too
and yeah
you're on lots of drugs oh dude i didn't
get don't say drugs well i mean
yeah do you remember your friend was
paralyzed for a year hey um
i tried i attempted that never happened
i tried i definitely never happened i uh
nope never i tried uh a bench at 4 30
yesterday i didn't get it i was so
[ __ ] close though it was pretty fun
how close was i louise luis diaz does
450. it does he on the bench that's
short flat for that and he's he pulls a
little short right like 30. i bet dude
yeah
so but i failed at 4 30 on camera damn i
know you were close that's the first
time i ever saw you like i think you got
to be careful i think you have to be
you're getting to be 40 i think you have
to be very careful you can do some dumb
[ __ ] like pull you know what i think you
have to be careful
i'm serious no no i'm serious i think
because whenever i say i'll send rogan
up video me bench like 400 or something
like that i'm like dude your shoulders
be careful
this is for you and him
i've been benching since fourth grade
shut up both of you shut up
i just go hey shut up something shut up
nope for you guys you can
shut up
i'm different
i'm not you guys i'm different it is
kind of odd to say to someone that
doesn't bench to tell someone that does
benches
when you're when you get to a certain
age and you're going where you actually
fail that's where dumb [ __ ] happens but
he was going for a lot of weight and i
did 405 so easy but yeah
and i do it every week dude you did four
or five easy
what yeah i can do it for like five
that's a lot of weight 405
god damn didn't get 430 though and we
had my boy
and we had my boy big mike lifting with
us or the fan lifted with us he did
three pretty easy he's at 315 for uh
six or five or six yeah you have very
strong what's your reach wrong dude 82
81 you got long arms man that's a long
way to go baby mike built like a uh big
mic built like a baby hippo huh
your best uh lift is probably deadlift
right
bench for my side is pretty good dad
loves the pull-ups
pull-ups i've always been good at
pull-ups for some reason and tigers get
a pull-ups he's really good at monkey
bars really rocks those monkey bars
his boy broke his arm oh that's that's
mike that's big mike big mike he's a
barrel chaser
he's not coming to shows for years seven
years dude he's never he's never missed
a local show i've ever done what wow and
then uh he came to the hob the before i
did the special he's like dude i see you
doing the contest to work out with you
guys like i [ __ ] i live like 40
minutes away man i'm so cool oh dude
just [ __ ] hit up
yeah he was doing that how about the guy
there's a video of a guy he's doing this
he's got a he's got 45 pounds and he's
got his feet here and he's and he's
going all the way back and then up and
it's and so is this going off yeah but
his legs are in the saddle
and he just
i'm not watching any more of these
videos oh you got it
[ __ ] don't scare you yeah
how about the guy yeah mark [ __ ] his
back up a little bit [ __ ] sleep today
yeah
yeah because we were doing uh he didn't
even go for 405 with us on the deadlift
yeah you don't want to be doing yeah
slipping this he's just he's just i'll
never attempt the time i've never
attacked him but he said he's saying hey
romero remember i come i kind of i'm
like [ __ ] my neck man i've been doing
neck exercises and you go where did i go
i was like 50 i go i was neck bridging
this morning and you go neck bridging
nice breaching i don't it's like a thing
we did on wrestling i used to do it all
the time but when you're young we used
to do neck braces with your friends
yeah that's all we did but it's not good
for your neck no well when you're young
it strengthens your neck but yeah yes
no you know you get paralyzed dude but
you could come back
look at that brian's just out there
that's what we used to do all the time i
don't think that's good there are other
there are better ways to do neck bridges
oh go go tell [ __ ] john smith
oklahoma state it's not good yeah that
worked out for you that's how they warm
up dude yep i know but they're next
though they're fine yeah
but that is what they do
look at mike tyson right now yeah he had
neck surgery we saw him after his neck
surgery i believe dude how about he's
[ __ ] doing uh poison frog drugs now
three times a day yeah what is that like
the uh it's a hallucination i guess you
take the you lick the frog or the the
like the
serum from the frog yeah it takes you
another
yeah really no it's it's they're using
it for psilocybin too they're finding
amazing results with psilocybin for for
oh no he looks at toads
toad venom so do you just have that toad
in your house and you're just licking
when you walk by
that toes
i think it's a whole it's part of this
whole psychedelic thing for a depression
psychedelic is popping dude like you
know i've had buddies with people micro
dose in it it really helps yeah i have
buddies with ptsd and uh and depression
depression yeah they give a micro dosing
of shrooms yeah so it's a really really
bad apparently it really does help
apparently tyson just walks by the stone
and licks them every now and then
really yeah the toad's like what the
[ __ ] do you think's the toad i i i don't
know how i would do it will you kiss the
tone i would do it you you do that [ __ ]
yeah it gets off of venom it has a venom
yeah you just got a little mushrooms and
toads like don't [ __ ] around because you
can touch the wrong poison arrow frog
and die well no tyson's not walking the
amazon rainforest just grabbing toads
and licking them where is that he's got
specific he's got something from like
actually america isn't it no that toad's
from [ __ ]
i thought it was from like south america
no way sonoma
there's no [ __ ]
psychedelic frog colorado river toad all
knows northern devastates foundation
that's not the one they lick dude
southwestern united states no no it does
that is the one
yeah that's the trendy toad huh isn't
that crazy that's the one that's out
here huh four to six times more powerful
than dmt now you and i did dmt and i was
lit give it up god is good got it i was
[ __ ] up was that when you all was
crying
i was ingested by licking the poisonous
feminine's back but it's now more
commonly consumed as a smokeable dust
form oh so you got to go to uh sohan
shaman's throughout mexico and
southwestern so like so texas new mexico
colorado that's southwestern right you
should go down there and pick up some
toast dude let's drive down there and
[ __ ] kidnap some toads dude let's
traffic toads all right
we're already selling it do they just
say how long they're going to selling no
fun toads why don't we do psychedelic
toads where it's like a toad like this
we do him real fat and he's like the
he's like the bear from grateful dead no
fun toasting like his eyes change colors
it's like a dmt too called so fun toad
so fun has it already happened no there
you go oh this is just creating it
psychedelic toads all right colorado
river toad there it is do we make one
with a mike tyson tattoo on his face
you're welcome whoever works now here's
my question i bet you the first time
they figured this out with somebody ate
one because they were hungry no i bet
somebody like oh hey you're probably
right someone's like i'm [ __ ]
starving and ate the and then was like
short what it's a 20-minute trip some
say 20 minutes 20 minutes is forever i
would yeah because i was i was blitzed
and it was uh a minute dude i was like
how long was that he was like a minute
at 30 i'm like holy [ __ ] what's up
five years we went summer special oh i
went somewhere so special i'll do it
i'll do that toad thing in a heartbeat
i'll do the toad thing in the right
corner i'll do trt toad stuff hair
transplant i'm gonna be [ __ ] awesome
do you give me a different get my teeth
whiten dude i get but where do we buy
these toads from i think the best thing
is we vlog it on thick boy and we go
down to new mexico and capture these
frogs i'll do it
but i wonder how crazy is down there i
bet it's pretty competitive that's
that's right
barbie marcus i guarantees has a has a
connection we just got to get a good
connection i actually have a very good
connection through these toes
yeah i got a healthy guy with buttocks i
got a richest [ __ ] dude who's a friend
who's
all about psychedelics like he's got
stupid money and they'd say there's that
community it's a risky i have a billion
dollars now what do i do like toads
they're all like i want to get closer to
god yeah
yeah why are celebrities smoking too oh
they smoke it no i just want to smoke it
they said they dry they dry the venom it
becomes a dust and then we smoke it the
wheat that's how we did dmt yeah we did
smoke it like crack yeah but i'll lick
it too and the dmt trip was what a
minute minute thirty minute thirty but
it felt like forever wow tell me call
this one
desert colorado river toad shout out to
colorado i think she doesn't speak out
and be found around snoring desert in
cal in california dude that's right up
the street but this isn't back our toad
i need that valley toad
there's someone else connections that'll
reach out to the show so it's a
psychedelic like silhouette
mushrooms lsd ketamine you ever done too
much ketamine not fun
you ever do they call it cahole you ever
been on a keyhole i've been on a cahill
and i want my girl to know because i
sniffed it
and i was deep in a k hole yeah well
well she was like what's wrong
sam triple is going to hit me with some
conspiracy theory knowledge he gives you
want some poppers or ketamine for your
ass because i'm going to get up in there
yeah with let's just help your ass yeah
you can take ketamine and apparently it
dilates your your your romper your hose
yeah like makes it smaller dilates
what you wanted to open it up your
[ __ ] yeah i guess ketamine is the sex
drug in the gay community as well
ketamine and uh
i thought it was just the poppers i
think can you look that up
isn't dilation making it bigger yes oh
dilation makes it bigger
so if you're wider people are dilated oh
they get bigger so what am i looking for
it opens up your ass highlights your
anus it relaxes your anus
it relaxes it take some poppers let me
talk to you and then you're my [ __ ]
you just opened i'm going to pop nice
got a gaping [ __ ] yeah like this look
i'm like i'm like hey man what are you
doing tonight take a breath oh my ass oh
no it loses it up huh yep and now you're
like this whoo and chappelle's best
friend is super gay yeah ask him if he
pops that stuff the power popper
his [ __ ] talks him right now
let's confirm this dude
ask him if he does ketamine or licks
toes to get his ass ready yeah
do you think they uh
yeah
do they do they dp did gay guys dp like
two dicks yeah one ass
they're guys the guys they're gonna
figure it out so guys gonna put all the
dicks in there yeah guys like yeah how
many people of course don't know how to
write this question
hey man
hey man quick question on the show we're
curious
in in your culture bro we're on the show
right now and you're here
and then put just just because
do you guys [ __ ] around with ketamine to
get ready
and he'll know exactly does ketamine in
your culture yeah ketamine and poppers
help you
get ready i know i think popper's such
an old popper your tongue is uh your
tongue is aggressively big it no it's
aggressively like it's a lot of
different colors is it yeah what have
you been doing poppers no toads
that's a [ __ ] toad tongue right there
brother
really oh colors look at that that look
at this look at this look at the color
of his tongue i'll take a picture of
that tongue well that's super red
well tons of red chin no no no no the
sides are super red
just drink water what do you why are you
looking why is
i've had eight shots of espresso i'm on
creatine i've i'm whisked up i haven't
eaten today but cat also said you don't
drink you don't drink water no like
that's like a terrible thing
[Laughter]
he's been ready he's always ready yeah
does he say get ready for my computer
yeah i get to
play with your ass
like
say get ready for you know maybe your
friend's a top so he doesn't need to use
it but she's your best friend so you can
talk to him however he's not you're not
yeah
yeah
dude i had so many gay questions for him
huh yeah i'm trying to come back like
you'd [ __ ] your bench right now hey bro
so when you go into the city is it just
one
and he's on my relationship i'm like i
get that it's you and me talking to him
yeah he's like well i'm going to open it
i'm like there we go
so when you go into town
are we just dumping loads you're a good
looking guy what
looking guy yeah yeah i've heard that
that's small
you small dude i've heard that tops are
rarer
than bottoms in the gay community there
you go that's your that is [ __ ] crazy
dude that looks like i don't know if
you're going to show this on air that
looks like a why not it just looks crazy
god not showing up you know
what are you 90 chin
i don't i think this is too graphic for
the kids
let's not show your tongue that was in
the back of the toad it looks crazy you
look that well a little dehydrated a
little i'm on whiskey whiskey that oh my
gosh that's a lot of coffee well my toe
oh my god i'm healthy that looks crazy
you know i have a really long time i got
a lot of great hairstyles
oh
[ __ ] that's impressive yeah
it's impressive brother can you do one
more time for the cameras
yeah yeah it's like it's like gene
simmons
yeah it's at a point like mine doesn't
go to a point flat me too we got we got
a couple yeah
yeah i don't know how that happened but
i just got it
no you're born like that dude yeah no he
he said uh
your friend don't [ __ ] around ketamine
he said poppers make you want to take
dick ketamine he just want to make it
just makes you feel [ __ ] up
poppers pumpers make you want to take
what are people
what is a popper i think it's called
animal nitrate hey chin
popper so i stay away from it's an
animal knife
i don't want power
relaxation effect on involuntary smooth
muscles such as those in the throat and
anus oh yeah
[Applause]
uh
to facilitate anal sex by increasing
blood flow and relaxing
sphincter muscles
yep drug is also used for recreational
drug purpose typically for a higher rush
than a drug can create oh yeah
i mean when you drink when you have that
that coffee rush everything is right in
the world if you just i never have it if
somebody came running those days are
there oh god those days all we chase is
that what sometimes you still get a
little hint of it it's like you you hear
it clearing its throat it's like i
remember you yeah and you're like oh
that's that coffee like for coffee yeah
y'all get like that i used to happen to
me without a roll now you just
i took ten minutes why were you taking
adderall because i was told it helps you
focus so i tried ten
millimeters of that yeah you have add
what is it called
milligrams
it's [ __ ] it's cocaine i was like
yeah well no it's a form of mouth it's
not cocaine yeah
i was so optimistic i was like
everything's great in the world oh i
thought it was the worst thing ever
would that be great though if you take
it every day yeah but i think it [ __ ]
with your come down i don't trust it yep
yeah that come down with superman that
feels that good i snorted it in college
it was dumb we're doing a million
bathroom 30 milligrams i can't imagine
30 milligrams i think uh meatball does
like yeah higher higher he does a very
high percentage yeah i've done i've done
30 before dude i've done 30 almost
finished a [ __ ] book yeah it's like
london i did 10 and i was like i did 30
milligrams i finished a book on a plane
and i could have [ __ ]
done a research
30 oh yeah
i i ten and i was like oh if if if i get
up late like let's say you get off stage
and you get home at like one am you know
six am flight yeah
and i'll wake up show groggy i'll pop up
i'll pop daddy has some in the reserve
right but how much do you take 30 really
30. so it just wakes you up you're not
tired but yeah you can handle 30. yeah
yeah you can make your rhinoceros but
you don't feel like it that [ __ ] your
adrenals up because then you're feeling
terrible i feel great yeah i'm high
right now i couldn't do it i'm drunk
right now i'm drunk right now i'm drunk
if i don't i i i i need my sleep if i
don't get myself yeah i don't help you
get through that though yeah so you're
not a baby back [ __ ] for the rest of
the day i'm a baby back [ __ ] hey here's
the thing
this is the plan that i think we should
do yeah so you're gonna get your hair
done yeah we know that that's why you
know that
you've agreed to do trt stevie's
convinced you do trt yeah and then we're
gonna do adderall
why are you pushing adderall on me and
then he said it already [ __ ] him up no
he loves it no we do small doses cause
you have add here's the thing though too
so your hair yeah easy i know where
you're going next you're here i know
hold
and you're already wearing color yeah i
know we're already changing our wardrobe
i know what you're going to do now life
god is good okay that's all that's it
are you done or are you going to hit me
up with something else when i hit you
with you you can leave there's nothing
to do but were looking at me i tried
doing yourself
that's up to you well i got to get
myself the rest is on me i gotta go no
god is good
god is good
that is good
dude you have a new kid come in the
world makes me sick dude do you think
about what kind of dad young dad dude
trt dad new here dad adderall dad yeah
new clothes
i need new clothes but you don't give me
any build [ __ ] man it's [ __ ] amazing
you don't give me any thick boys dude
it's actually i'll have bill dude that's
what i'm gonna do when we get out of my
text belt to send you a whole package
you're gonna wear those shirts every day
seriously yeah you're gonna love you're
gonna love them they're the best [ __ ]
shirt medium yeah right yep medium for
sure you're gonna love them remember
shoulders don't you want shoulders
shoulders chest trt that's all that's
all it took we've been trying to
convince through the trt for years
do you know who a conventional let me
take my shirt off tell me what you think
do you think he's really going to
[ __ ] do trt i think he's open to it
if you have a wife be there i'm going to
hit you hold up right let me oh
you're built like yellow bastard from
sin city like you you got abs and [ __ ]
bring up yellow bastards
i'll do it you go do that let's do that
hey look at that
it's the rear delt
[Laughter]
look there's brian right there
no your body for your age it's not bad
but
you you're losing a little bit i love
your confidence for taking your shirt
off
i'm losing the muscle i work out because
there's brian as the old bastard but
brian remember when you flexed on rogan
remember when we were out doing the
fight command you flexed on there
my pack is not bad it is funny that he
does wear a white beater
the only guy i know that keeps wife
beaters in business
see i'd buy that picture i'm gonna frame
that
what
i'm gonna frame that
hey brian
i'll be i'll get more yeah yeah 100
hey you know you look like that guy
though right you have the same face
and his name is yellow bastard yeah he
has a bigger gut he's terrible in that
movie he's a [ __ ] terrible person no
he's the worst oh my god he's vile dude
yellow
bastard he's so good at rogan's like
tommy
oh wow they did rogan next to yellow
bastard that didn't make sense well you
get older and no matter what you do
you're still going to look you just body
starts to change about diet
yeah or just take it and also follow the
times
yeah the time goes and muscle but really
it's testosterone when your testosterone
is really low your body stops your body
starts sucking yeah
all right i'm gonna go on trt
and then i'll take my shirt off you got
a guy for him stevie yeah i got a guy
i'll use uh i got a guy
a doctor that rogan uses
that'll work
yeah just go get it checked out man
i better get checked out all right jim
what do you got but me i just may not be
a muscular guy i'm skinny dude but trt
they have no choice
yeah but then i'll just look like do you
really want to take it
no but i do kind of i don't know so
see i i just don't want my body in the
way i wanna i want to like be able to do
the [ __ ] i do and have energy yeah
you have more energy
i do now yeah definitely you sound like
this stevie has a good body stevie
stevie
yeah yeah even on trt and [ __ ]
adderall steven you're way bigger yeah
are you taking adderall too no no no no
no no you've taken that though yeah yeah
i never i i didn't stimulants i never
got along with yeah i never really
needed it you just do trt yeah i just do
trt
you don't like any drugs right no we
don't even drink anymore i haven't drank
since when was you feel better the mark
san antonio antonio oh you were drinking
there that's the last time we're really
drinking oh yeah oh there's san marcos
san marcos
longevity doctor and he said one of the
worst things you can do is people drink
juice like orange juice because that's
like foreign
always asking for apple juice he's the
skinniest guy too skinny
well you know orlando and you see that
disney world group the loose people in
the world
otherwise people they live on just they
live on
sugar no they're they're they're built
on funnel cakes you know i mean you go
to disneyland it's the other people in
the world i mean i do love a good funnel
first team all ugly yeah but every day
you're right and they put gravy and [ __ ]
on it what else you got jen
[Laughter]
here we go
so recently a australian news outlet
paid almost a million dollars to score a
interview with adele because she has an
album coming out a million dollars uh
yeah they charged about 700 000 for it
just to have her talk about promoting
her interesting yeah i don't know who it
goes to whether it goes directly to her
or her record label sony somebody gets
that money yeah um and there were
different articles coming out because
the host that they sent to do the
interview with her had a 20-minute slot
where he would ask about her album and
it turns out he actually didn't listen
to the album prior to
doing the interview
and so uh he said that when he got there
he was sent an e-link to it that he
hadn't gotten he says it went to spam
folder or something either way he didn't
listen to it he came to the interview
tried to do it and you revealed that he
actually didn't listen to the album
during the interview during the
interview because she asked for his
opinion on something and he said oh if
i'm going to be honest i didn't listen
to it and a lot of outlets are saying
that she stormed out but he's saying
that she was actually really nice about
it and actually extended the interview
an extra nine minutes and they talked
and it was great but sony isn't
releasing the foot the interview because
he didn't know that what was on the
album it should release it so they're
still gonna pay her though yeah they she
still got paid uh i think sony still got
paid but they're not releasing the
actual interview for him and the
australian news outlet apparently it's
all about her um it's about her divorce
yeah yeah divorced teams she can only
sing in pain she says yeah because
before this she said she wasn't going to
make another album unless she had her
heart broken and then she had a divorce
but now she's having a heart broken
through her kid she's like she feels bad
because she broke up with her she can
write songs man she can show she was
married to a chef or something like that
something like that something like a
famous chef that's amy uh schumer i
think right
yeah she's making a show
yeah i'm with you
well he just didn't do his work nice to
spend the two weeks
probably biggest interview he's ever
done he don't yeah he said that was the
most important email he never got
he definitely got it he definitely got
he just didn't listen to it also he's
lazy i would definitely be listening to
like know the album yeah adele dude you
don't need an email i don't need anyone
give me the album yeah it's on itunes
i'm gonna read if i'm so you know how to
get the link if kanye west is wrote a
book and i'm gonna interview him i'm
gonna read the book
the internet is currently making fun of
kyle kuzma for wearing this gigantic
pink sweater so keep scrolling down
this is the modern day do you remember
lenny kravitz with that gigantic scarf
he was rocking oh yeah yeah this is the
the clown right yeah
how's he grab stuff that's it that guy
is a basketball player yeah he's from
australia
good player i mean
he can almost put her off he's a good
looking [ __ ] so ain't no [ __ ]
way
before that i'm not pressing the like
button lebron said ain't no [ __ ] way
you wore that i'm not pressing the like
button because this guy's outrageous but
man that [ __ ] fire that is not fire you
out of line
that's great yeah that is a horrible i'd
have to twerk you got to get in the hell
no you got to get roasted for that yeah
that's i mean
come on kill it
it's cold out
[Laughter]
real fun right no that's that's all
that's that's during the
might be a little uh there's just
reactions oh okay yeah there's just
people making funny reactions
that's just blowing up that's funny
that's really funny man the conspiracy
thing people go ahead people think
lebron uh
because he's been getting so much flack
for the china stuff he refuses to talk
about it they think he hit that guy in
the face to take the distraction away
from his because when he does the
interviews all it is about china like
what's your opinion tragic so he does
that it completely deflects
and so now they're asking about the hit
that's all they're talking about
interesting because he's never done that
before right it's very interesting
[Laughter]
i take some fashion wrists but that [ __ ]
is off that's different that's different
this doesn't make sense who's molly
morris that's what i'm looking at right
now
i don't know
not mad at her
so this was a bummer apparently there is
a texas youth football team that joined
a league last year they did really well
last year and this year they've
literally been on a non-stop winning
streak they have beat every single team
apparently their total score currently
is 199 points to six throughout the
entire season
they were just molly whopping this
entire year
and two weeks prior to this decision
they played the director of this
league's team and they molly wopped him
like basically his team did not get one
single touchdown two weeks later that
director actually banned them from being
in the playoffs because they said it's
not fair for him that's so so this
winning team to be in the playoffs
because they're so good that's the world
and he's then blaming it on the parents
of the other team saying oh they
actually threatened saying that they
would do something if this team was put
in the playoffs so they are too good i
feel admit they're a select level team
they're too good for a rec level team
they're probably they're so they're
probably like recruiting and stuff yeah
quarterbacks probably 27 years old
they're all between the ages of seven
and eight
seven eight seven and eight what about
this is in flower mountain shout out to
flower mound
but it would be weird if that team's
like a
you know like a competitive like super
league were they getting the best
players from different counties well
this basically and other teams are just
like yeah yeah well they built the book
this woman
her
her brother her two brothers played in
the nfl her dad played in the nfl
i mean craig and then she
had a child with a man who played in the
nfl so they have a child the little boy
and he's like eight and he's just like
he was just literally running through
everyone
and the question was as good as he was
they were talking about cte and whether
or not she wants to keep him in it but
he was so made for football
but but she said the men and her family
have issues so the dilemma was this kid
is so naturally made for football
i mean yeah but and also issues what
issues
i mean
yeah
all of them
if your kid is if your kid is that good
he's that gifted yeah and also the rules
are changing you're not banging head as
much i don't know i don't know i don't
know what else you got jen
already here
this is the one i was referring to
earlier where chrissy teigen had posted
that she got an eyebrow hair transplant
she said why are people so riled up why
you think yeah people just can't stand
her
yeah
i mean i don't know before oh no this is
the stencil right now and this is what
it looked like afterwards they're going
to calm down after uh like a few weeks
for recovery but i don't give a [ __ ]
about her personally so i don't care
what she does she actually had that fat
removal too from her cheeks yeah it
definitely helped
dude i've seen her in person though not
a pretty girl no yeah i've seen her her
body is [ __ ] no she's like a
hunchback and yeah i don't get it
that's weird because she used to be a
model that thought that's crazy i don't
know maybe posture [ __ ] up yeah she
was like she's like it's not good
just [ __ ]
nothing like nothing's least sexy the
hunchback
yeah i don't like a curved back
i'm not into the bad posture like that
no shrimp like posture yeah she got
canceled and then she just like she went
off twitter and then came back and then
she saw the pizzagate [ __ ] like yeah to
me it just feels like she's the girl who
thrived off of attention she got on
social media and then they turned on her
and now she's still trying to like she
drives off that attention she's driving
off of being horrible yeah exactly
because she got attention she got
attention for it yeah telling a teenager
to kill herself privately she also was
texting that girl privately dming her
privately and saying take a dirt nap
woke up fantasizing about you taking the
german you should kill yourself a 16
year old so she's a piece of [ __ ] she
was older too yeah she was an adult
she's like she was thirty yeah she's
like no that's not really amazing yeah
it is you're a piece yeah she said it
you said it and she and there is a
record and she refuses to kind of go
away mm-hmm what was the reason that she
even knew that 16 because the girl the
girl married all over the world she
didn't know the six-year-old she was
dating she was she married a 51 year old
oh that one
suicide
bad person yeah yeah that's who that's
who she is
that's who she is hopefully she changes
all right so this is just an update on
that whole brian laundry and gabby
petito he shot himself right yeah before
it was like inconclusive they didn't
know what happened but yeah they said
they were just holding out yeah but i
tell you what story i don't give a [ __ ]
suicide is this one right
it's just like
once they found them yeah they had a
very they had a very very troubled
relationship right they were always like
fighting and stuff she had depression
what was the i don't know he choked her
and killed her yeah and then she they
would like vlog their trips through
north i think they i didn't even know
about this but i guess they did like a
van life type of yeah they're big yeah
yeah
100
um this is a bald eagle
grabbing a shark after a guy caught it
kind of shark without him out not sure
but it is pretty cool watch
all of your swoops just still happen to
me in the last florida
there's like all these people standing
around what do you do fight the eagle no
i'm saying the eagle doesn't care about
the people
he's trying to use the eagle sees that
food yeah you're gonna cut the hook you
gotta go get pictures it should happen
to me it's [ __ ] alaska did it really
bro no it never happened
well okay brian tell me your story
eating right now okay but the guy did
throw fish into the water and a ball
deal came down and grabbed it in front
of us
i don't know if it was on my line i
can't remember
there's a little shark yeah yeah they're
a lot of baby sharks along the shoreline
this is a very sweet story a high school
quarterback
scored actually eight touchdowns after
his mother passed away from cancer
and there's speaker tom brady why
i'm surprised
it's the article his article
red banner
this is like just
just him balling out after his mama died
get it bro
his mom died from cancer yeah from
cancer jesus christ so that was pretty
cool yeah
uh did you so i'm not sure anyone here
even cares about wwe but then i thought
this was a scripted thing but a fan
tackled this guy seth rollins
and it was not scripted it was a real
thing that's not play center
[Music]
somebody just jumps out they get yeah
knocked out
we're obviously not going to have a
match
so that's a fan that came in and tackled
seth rollins
and they switched the cameras focus on
the fake guys
that's it we can't see them now we have
more way more
you guys in sweat
that [ __ ] was that heated
and watched look i don't know how this
guy even got got in how the [ __ ] did he
go boom
i mean he double likes the [ __ ] yeah
but if you're caught by surprise you
know that's definitely a trick
it goes all fat yeah that's a fan look
at him look how uh
that rollins guy's kicking him he went
for a choke
and he's still playing it up
what the [ __ ] is going on bro
i was able to just jump back exactly
that's the crazy part that's [ __ ]
insane but also how's that rolling yeah
how about that roland's takedown defense
not good
but you're blindsided though you see it
yeah he's totally blindsided
i don't know he's part of him he barely
sees him here his head turns he sees it
he said turns
and then here that's a big heavy guy
yeah that's a really big guy too big boy
big out of shape guys for sure but
there's a lot of magazines for like a
weird guillotine yeah get him in there
and [ __ ] he heated about that [ __ ]
wrestling match yeah but so that wasn't
a scripted thing that was a real thing
the guy's up for
i don't know some charges i don't know
yeah
that's [ __ ] insane how the [ __ ] did
he get he got hit he got hit hard yeah
you got rocked him that was out of
nowhere there's a lot of mass heading
towards them yeah those guys have you
gotta rock them
um okay
have you guys seen this
no he's so old yeah
end of quote they're all well [ __ ]
i forgot what it was for but now
everyone just lets it like fly like
whatever dude yeah yeah he's an old guy
imagine if trump did that how much how
gross did he get he's younger than trump
isn't he no he's older than trump is he
oh yeah yeah he's [ __ ] 79 dude okay
let me just play this for you
yeah so i guess there's like you know
different scripts they have even when we
do reads here yeah they'll say like okay
just mention this do this you're not
supposed to read that yeah he read all
this so he read parts of the scriptures
together with your family this
thanksgiving i want you to know how
grateful i am
to serve as your president
so i promised you that i'll never stop
working to address your family's needs
and together we're going to confront
challenges that we face them are going
to face them honestly that's the part
you shouldn't be keep building this
economy around hardworking folks who
built this country
so happy thanksgiving god bless you and
may god protect our troops and i'm
heading to a
so just that part was like a walmart
read for the walmart oh yeah i know he
said that accidentally he's so robotic
yeah he does he says end quote here huh
where's end quote
end quote do they say end quote food
kitchen to serve electric troops
thank you for your time and effort now
plenty of time to talk to you
oh he like whispered as he walked away
the white house [ __ ] ages you in
general yeah and he's sparring his words
do you mention 79 have to [ __ ] read
all the time like this in public yeah
it's a [ __ ] beast
yeah
yeah that's that means what can i do
kids i gotta run you gotta run oh yeah
you gotta fight to catch up 335. you
wanna just end this right now though one
more just a quick uh
is it good or is it like you finished it
i didn't know what this animal was but
you like noses right so
this is yeah it's appearing
what is that that thing is cute
someone give me some poppers
they're indigenous to south america and
i th maybe
is it of the pig family they're
definitely they're definitely uh jaguar
food or something oh is that a tapir
though it's a paper it's a pierce
whatever that is cute
yeah basically me when i eat a daddy's
cute cute
oh when they get older where are they
from
yeah like a little pig with cute noses
that's great these things are [ __ ]
that's it hi kids this saturday me and
chappelle will be live in everett
washington that [ __ ] almost sold out
everett theater washington one night
only this saturday november 27th then
dania florida fort lauderdale fort
lauderdale improv the old fort
lauderdale improv bring in the new years
with your thick friends december 30th
through january 1st that is coming up
but this saturday see you soon everett
washington also thick boy restocking
restocking the whole goddamn website
that's sold out it'll be 25 off the
whole website jerseys the built camo
workout gear the joggers everything will
be restocked at 9am on friday morning at
thickboy.com get your song
and brian
uh kids boca raton florida laughing
spree comedy festival december 3rd one
night only kansas city missouri improv
december 17 1819 oklahoma city bricktown
comedy club december 30th january 1st
salt lake city utah wise guys january 6
7 8 get your tickets i can't wait
and then december 1st san jose improv
one night only 8 p.m boom
boom love you guys happy turkey day
happy thanksgiving happy indigenous day
or whatever it is love you guys happy
thanksgiving